tutto attorno a noi sta cambiando
velocemente molto velocemente ma questa
probabilmente è la nuova velocità di
cannes
se consideriamo che per raggiungere 50
milioni di utenti
la televisione la radio hanno impiegato
decine di anni 38 anni per la radio 14
anni per la televisione
facebook ha impiegato quattro anni e
raggiunge 50 minuti utenti ipad 80
giorni quindi le tecnologie stanno
andando molto velocemente ma anche la
comunicazione
tutti abbiamo in tasca milioni di
twitter che ci arrivano ogni minuto 3
milioni di twitter
decine di milioni di like decine di
migliaia di ore di video caricati su
tutti i social network sono informazioni
informazioni che vanno ad una velocità
molto molto superiore rispetto a quella
che c'è sempre stata negli anni
cosa sta succedendo qualcuno l'ha
chiamata terza rivoluzione industriale
che mette insieme la comunicazione
l'energia e la tecnologia per la
tecnologia in particolare ci sono
quattro cinque settori trainanti che
saranno i settori del futuro e che sono
in parte anche già settori del presente
la stampa tridimensionale il digitale
internet delle cose internet of things e
lascerà in economy
cosa che ci toccano tutti i giorni e che
ci influenzeranno sempre di più nel
futuro e forse non ce ne rendiamo conto
così bene il digitale come sapete è un
mondo un mondo che si sta ridefinendo un
mondo che a 7 miliardi di utenti attivi
che partecipano che comprano l'e
commerce
sembra che a vedere potenzialità di
moltiplicare per cinque i propri
fatturati nei prossimi cinque anni
e noi sembra già che siano molto molto
molto presenti 4 2 trillioni di dollari
e il potenziale del mercato digitale nei
prossimi anni quindi con un'espansione
che ben superiori spetta a quella che
abbiamo visto finora
questo anche perché c'è molta ricerca
dietro molti investimenti
ogni anno ormai da tempo aumentano del
20 per cento gli investimenti in
software e in internet
e ciò nonostante il settore prende
ancora una
quella percentuale un 8 per cento di
quello che è il mercato della ricerca e
sviluppo
quindi vuol dire che c'è moltissimo
spazio non ti dispiace per cosa un
signore che era abbastanza lungimirante
probabilmente visto che ha investito in
facebook linkedin in quelli che sono ad
oggi le aziende digitali che hanno avuto
più successo e probabilmente i
moltiplicatori più alti
essendo dei servizi anche con dei
risultati abbastanza interessanti dal
punto di vista dell'azionista ha detto
una cosa interessante
il software si sta mangiando il mondo
i software non sono soltanto delle cose
astratte i software stanno creando delle
aziende reali stanno creando dei
risultati che sono assolutamente
tangibili e in parte probabilmente il
software stanno anche ridefinendo quella
che la geografia che normalmente
utilizziamo di riferimento
tutti noi abbiamo nelle aziende parliamo
di brick parliamo di amy a parliamo dei
mercati emergenti
diamo delle geografie che sono quelle
quelle fisiche quella cui siamo abituati
brasile russia india cina il mercato
domestico mercato estero bene
probabilmente ci sono delle nuove
geografie e una di queste si chiama ga
un nuovo mercato
un uomo con dei confini che non sono
quelli geografici amazon google facebook
apple
queste quattro aziende insieme hanno una
capitalizzazione di borsa doppia
rispetto a quella che abbiamo noi in
italia con tutte le nostre aziende
quotate al mibac sono 80 40 aziende che
vanno all 80 per cento del capitale di
azionariato pubblico che valgono 440
miliardi di dollari queste quattro
aziende da solo ne valgono esattamente
il doppio
e questo dà da pensare forse triplo
il primo pilastro quindi il digitale il
mondo del digitale un secondo pilastro
stampa tridimensionale la stampa
tradizionale ha invertito il paradigma
il paradigma del costruire le cose
togliendo e sottraendo materiale il
pensiero esattamente contrario si
aggiunge partendo dal nulla è una cosa
nuova
assolutamente no ha cambiato nome si
chiama stereolitografia poi diventato ha
detto mano factoring adesso in modo
molto più cool
si chiama stampa tridimensionale stampa
3d ma cosa ci si può fare beh se
iniziata con gli aerei gli aerei che
sono uno dei primi settori quello
aeronautico dove è stato è stato
sviluppato tra stampa dimensionale
perché perché sono piccoli volumi con
altissima qualità e quindi visto che la
stampa di mensile ha bisogno di tempo
per essere prodotto dal nulla questo
questo prodotto
gli aerei erano perfetti come tipo di
settore
però la cosa sta evolvendo i materiali
sono diversi sistemi iniziando
utilizzare per le protesi per esempio
molto diffuse per parti del corpo organi
l'orecchio bionico
quindi il nostro mondo è sempre più
invaso di tecnologia tridimensionale
anche su cose molto più semplici per
esempio un automobile è stata fatta la
prima automobile completamente stampata
in tridimensionale che funziona e può
andare in giro ma probabilmente anche la
nostra vita di tutti i giorni
quando andremo in un negozio di scarpe
entreremo ci sarà commesso avrà uno
scanner in mano farà la scansione del
piede e poi uscirà dal retrobottega con
le nostre scarpe quale il numero non è
importante
sono diversi i due numeri pagare sono
anche diversi e prenderanno esattamente
la forma del nostro piede
questo è un mercato che sta escludendo
che sta crescendo tantissimo come volumi
sia dalla parte di produzione che per la
parte di produzione delle macchine che
producono le stampanti dimensionali
perché ovviamente qualcuno ha subito
inventato la macchina
stampa le macchine tridimensionale sono
cose lontane da noi una stampante
dimensionale ad oggi cosa 600 euro
quindi è anche possibile che qualcuno di
noi tra qualche anno avrà in casa la
propria stampante tridimensionale uscirà
il negozio comprare una bobina di filo
la inserirà nella 60 dimensionale e
deciderà di stamparsi un bicchiere una
posata un aggeggio qualsiasi che si
vuole produrre da solo ma questo cosa
vuol dire vuol dire che ci faremo le
cose esattamente come le vorremmo vorrà
dire che probabilmente le fabbriche
avranno un utilità diversa non usciremo
più per andare nel negozio a comprare un
prodotto ci scaricheremo un file che
qualcuno avrà prodotto che potrebbe
essere una nuova competenza che una
professionalità che arriva sul mercato e
ci stamperemo il nostro prodotto senza
consumare la benzina per andare a
comprarlo senza sprecare materiale che
che dovremmo buttare via e avendo
esattamente quello che ci serve
e magari chissà noi diventeremo un punto
di una fabbrica diffusa che sarà diffusa
in tutto il mondo quindi quello che
interessante non è tanto la tecnologia
quanto i modelli di business che la
tecnologia può attivare perché noi non
siamo tutti dei tecnici e quindi ci
interessa relativamente sapere come
funziona ma il modello di business che
cambia la nostra vita
questo sicuramente ci deve interessare
il terzo e non ultimo argomento pilastro
della tecnologia della terza rivoluzione
terze l'uso industriale e internet delle
cose internet of things quali cose tutte
la nostra casa per esempio la nostra
casa potrà essere comandata senza nessun
senza nessuna difficoltà perché ci sarà
questa famosa usability con un tasto noi
potremo attivare un meccanismo che
quando ci svegliamo al mattino e la
sveglia ci apre svegliato cinque minuti
prima perché c'è coda in autostrada tra
scaldare la nostra macchina
noi saremo in macchina quando saremmo
saliti la macchina dirà alla casa in
montagna che si della cenere
riscaldamento perché stiamo arrivando
il bollitore inizierà a far scaldare
l'acqua e senza far niente noi
arriveremo in montagna la casa sarà
calda e ci potremo prendere il nostro
tempo ma questo non vale soltanto per
per la vita domestica
ovviamente vale per le aziende le
fabbriche intelligenti sono delle
fabbriche che hanno la possibilità di
muovere il le attrezzature di accendere
le luci di far funziona il robot
soltanto grazie a dei sensori e l'uomo è
l'uomo per prima cosa avrò più tempo per
pensare e secondo diventerà esperto nel
creare questi sistemi
quindi è sicuramente un evoluzione
un'evoluzione attorno alla quale
possiamo essere d'accordo o non
d'accordo ma sicuramente visto che
succederà una posizione a bisogna
prendere si potrà decidere di resistere
oppure di trovare il modo per vivere al
meglio e non essere sopraffatti le città
ovviamente saranno immerse di cose che
si parlano
la mobilità gli immobili le strade
l'illuminazione tutta sarà comandata in
un modo automatico e sicuramente più
efficiente e poi addosso a noi
vestiremo degli oggetti ovviamente degli
oggetti che si parleranno tra di loro
avremo un orologio che potrà mandare
messaggi che potrà misurare il nostro
battito cardiaco e avvertire il medico
se per caso ci sono dei problemi
imprevisti sulla nostra salute
e questa cosa succederà in che modo
succederà in un modo virale in un modo
esponenziale
ognuno di noi è previsto che nel 2020
avrà 7 di vice addosso collegati con
altre 50 miliardi
potremmo decidere di non metterli
comunque ci saranno 50 miliardi di cose
che si parleranno tra di loro creando un
un mercato che è stato stimato in 14
trilioni di dollari
bene il futuro però è adesso
e qual è il modo migliore per predire il
futuro e cercare di crearlo e plasmarlo
a nostra immagine e somiglianza
ma come facciamo noi che non siamo
general electrics che non siamo google
che non siamo facebook
beh sicuramente come minimo dobbiamo
cambiare la nostra mentalità e imparare
a sfruttare quello che c'è fuori quindi
questa innovazione esterna
il primo problema che dobbiamo superare
e alla barriera culturale
il motivo 60 per cento delle persone che
sono state intervistate in un'intervista
dell'economist qualche anno fa ha detto
che non fa innovazione aperta perché non
si fida non si fida perché le proprie
idee possono essere rubate da qualcun
altro non riesce a parlare con culture
diverse non riesce a parlare con persone
che ragiona in modo diverso i primi tre
motivi non sono la mancanza di soldi
come uno potrebbe immaginare ma è la
capacità culturale di poter lavorare con
altre persone e fidarsi di altre persone
sicuramente bisognerà imparare a
valorizzare la nostra innovazione ad
oggi diamo per scontato che per fare
innovazione bisogna partire da un punto
e arrivare alla fine con un prodotto con
un servizio completo non è detto
noi possiamo occuparci di un pezzo
possiamo generare delle idee che entrano
in un fan di innovazione ea un certo
punto ne escono perché qualcuno le
compra per fare il suo prodotto
oppure possiamo partire da un certo
punto introdurre innovazione esterna e
uscire con un nostro prodotto e poi
sicuramente bisogna imparare a usare i
tool che sono a nostra disposizione
fortunatamente con gli anni questa cosa
è diventata più accessibile a tutti
non sono soltanto più le grandi aziende
le uniche che hanno la possibilità di
usare delle tecnologie come il crowd
funding crowdsourcing per poter trovare
da
estremamente l'innovazione ea
disponilità di tutti tutti noi possiamo
tutti i giorni acquistare innovazione
dall'esterno tramite delle piattaforme
che sono nate esattamente per quello e
poi parlando delle aziende bisogna anche
imparare a essere più veloci c'è un
grande grande progetto di general
electrics che siano a faust words che
sta imponendo di un elettrici di
lavorare come una start up
questo per dire che si può anche parlare
seriamente di start up è stata possono
fare delle cose serie e il modo di farlo
è la cosa più serie che stanno usando le
grandi aziende per essere molto più
efficienti generale tricks imprime che a
livello di innovazione probabilmente una
delle prime aziende al mondo
poi ci sono dei modi anche più più
veloci comprare l'innovazione
esternamente
google ha deciso di ridurre l'impegno
sui propri laboratori e di creare un
fondo da 1,2 miliardi di dollari per
comprare tecnologie innovazione e start
up
la buona notizia è che ci sono anche 150
105 milioni di dollari che sono
stanziati per l'europa quindi anche noi
possiamo essere fautori dell'innovazione
di grandi aziende come come google
questo tema del corpo e venture capital
è una delle modalità che si sta trovando
nel mondo per fare innovazione più
flessibile per trovare esternamente
delle modalità di riduzione di rischio e
di aumento dell'efficienza
dell'innovazione molto diversa da quella
che storicamente è stata usata e cioè
creando dei laboratori di ricerca e
sviluppo che ovviamente servono per un
certo tempo devono essere rinnovati
l'innovazione esterna vuol dire avere
collaborazioni con tutto il mondo
cercando di fare delle partnership
permettono di sviluppare tutti quanti
l'innovazione insieme ognuno per il suo
pezzo è una grande bolla è possibile
forse sì comunque quando sarà scoppiata
sicuramente qualcosa ci lascerà
conoscenza capacità di fare apertura
mentale capace di socializzazione e poi
comunque lavorare sulle idee conviene
sempre perché come si sa sulle persone
che si incontrano si scambiano neuro se
ognuna se ne va con un euro se due
persone che si incontrano
un'idea ognuno se ne va quando idee